Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Mi hijo tiene cuatro años
y le encanta saltar en el sillón.
Yo le explico que se puede lastimar
y le pido que por favor no lo haga.
"Pero mirá papá", dice,
y sigue saltando.
Y siempre está a punto de romperse
la cabeza contra la mesa ratona.
Entonces le grito "Goran",
mi hijo se llama Goran,
"Goran dejá de saltar ya mismo".
Y cuando le clavo ese grito
tampoco me da bola.
(Risas)
Ahora imaginemos esta otra situación.
Mi hijo está saltando,
arriba-abajo, arriba-abajo,
y de pronto se resbala y está
muy cerca de partirse el cráneo
contra la punta de la mesa ratona.
Así que yo, su padre, fuerte
y valiente, me arrojo y lo salvo.
Lo traigo al piso y después de chequear
que el nene esté bien le digo:
"Goran, tenemos que hablar".
Lo tomo de la mano
y lo llevo a dar un paseo.
Imaginemos que no estamos en mi casa.
Estamos en una inmensa pradera en África.
Imaginemos también que arriba nuestro
hay un cielo estrellado.
Imaginemos que, de pronto,
suena una orquesta.
(Música)
"Gorán, estoy muy decepcionado de ti,
me desobedeciste deliberadamente,
te podrías haber lastimado".
"Pero papá, yo solo quería
ser valiente como tú".
"Yo soy valiente cuando debo ser valiente.
Gorán, verás, ser valiente
no significa ponerte en peligro".
"Pero papá, tú no le tienes miedo a nada".
"Sí, hoy tuve miedo".
"¿De veras?"
"Sí, hoy tuve miedo
de que te pasara algo a ti".
Y en el momento en que termino mi frase,
mi pequeño hijo ve la huella
de mis borceguíes en el suelo
y la compara con la de su zapatilla.
Y entonces recuerda que mido el doble,
que peso cinco veces más,
y que llevo en esta tierra 32 años
más que él y que ese número, 32,
nunca se va a achicar
hasta el día en que yo me muera.
(Fin de la música)
(Aplausos)
No es lo mismo.
No es lo mismo porque esto que acabo
de hacer es una escena de "El rey león".
Los dibujos animados,
con música, con personajes,
con historias, transmiten mensajes
y lo hacen de un modo muy potente.
Lo sentimos en el cuerpo.
Cuando era chico mi película favorita
era "El rey león".
La veía todo el tiempo.
"El rey león" tiene una frase
que me encanta
en una canción que dice "hakuna matata".
Hakuna matata significa
"sin problemas", en suajili.
Y también es la filosofía
que el pequeño Simba
adopta cuando su padre muere.
El leoncito está lleno de culpa,
lleno de angustia,
y adopta una filosofía de vida
que más o menos dice
"sin preocuparse es como hay que vivir".
Sin embargo, cuando crecí y tuve
un hijo y volví a ver "El rey león",
descubrí que "hakuna matata" es
simplemente una etapa en la vida de Simba.
Vivir en el bosque,
con tus amigos, comiendo bichos,
sin preocuparte por absolutamente nada
que no sea tu deseo y tu libertad.
Pero lo que Simba realmente tiene
que hacer es asumir sus responsabilidades,
volver con su manada,
ocupar el lugar de su padre,
derrotar al mal y restablecer
el ciclo de la vida.
Esto es el opuesto absoluto
de "hakuna matata".
El rey león me dijo a los 10 años
cómo iban a ser mis 20
y con qué los iba a superar a los 30.
A mi hermana le gustaba "La sirenita".
Se sabía todas las canciones.
Ahora dice que "La sirenita"
no le gusta mucho
porque "ninguna mujer debería
entregar su voz por un hombre".
Yo creo que mi hermana
no volvió a ver "La sirenita" de grande
porque en la película la princesa Ariel
quiere estar con el príncipe Eric
pero vive reprimida por
el poder patriarcal del rey Tritón.
Es verdad, entrega su voz,
¡pero es un acto desesperado!
Y no es hasta que recupera la voz
que puede estar con el chico
que ella quiere.
En "La sirenita", la mujer muda
nunca logra lo que quiere.
Además, Ariel es un personaje
que en toda la película nunca jamás
afloja con su deseo.
Y en esa aventura logra que
su padre cambie de parecer.
"La sirenita" es la historia
del deseo femenino sexual reprimido
que tiene que salir,
y el poder masculino que tiene
que hacerse a un lado y escuchar.
¿Cuánto de la incomodidad de mi hermana
con los mandatos patriarcales
tuvo que ver con "La sirenita"?
¿Cuánto de las decisiones
que yo tomé en mi vida
tuvieron que ver con "El rey león"?
Cada vez que hablo de esto
en la radio o en cualquier lado,
cada vez que hablo de la filosofía
de los dibujos animados,
viene alguien y dice:
"No tienen mensaje, son comerciales".
Sí, son comerciales,
sí ganan millones de dólares,
pero pueden hacerlo porque
tienen un contenido filosófico.
Una película como "Frozen",
por ejemplo, que costó USD 150 millones,
sin contar la promoción,
está obligada a ser significativa.
Además de los dibujos,
además de las canciones,
además de la enorme
maquinaria de promoción,
está obligada a resonar con
el tiempo histórico que le ha tocado.
Y "Frozen" lo hace.
Se mete en la discusión feminista
sobre las princesas.
Y ¿qué hace?
Las vuelve proactivas
y las aleja del amor romántico.
Todo sin tocar los zapatitos,
los vestidos y las coronitas.
Los dibujos animados
forman una visión de mundo.
Esto ya lo dijeron en el año 1971
los autores Dorfman y Mattelart
en su libro clásico de la filosofía
"Para leer al Pato Donald",
así se llama.
Ese libro tiene un capítulo final con
una frase que me encanta y que dice:
"mientras su cara risueña
deambule inocentemente
por las calles de nuestro país,
mientras Donald sea poder
y representación colectiva,
el imperialismo y la burguesía
podrán dormir tranquilos".
Para esos autores
el enemigo número uno del socialismo
era un pato sin pantalones.
(Risas)
Y tenían razón, porque la guerra
entre el socialismo y el Pato Donald
la ganó el pato.
Pasaron ya 50 años de este libro.
Mucho de los valores con los cuales
se criticaba a Disney en los 70
desde la izquierda,
fueron absorbidos por el mismo Disney
y por toda la industria
del entretenimiento infantil.
Se decía, por ejemplo,
que Disney era racista.
Pero en los 80 y los 90 junto con
los protagonistas blancos y cristianos
aparecieron judíos, musulmanes,
gitanos y chinos.
Y luego aparecieron mexicanos,
afroamericanos y polinesios.
Incluso hoy, hace muy poquito,
tenemos una película como Zootopía
que es, básicamente,
un gran argumento anti-racista.
Se decía que Disney era misógino.
Y si bien las princesas de los 90
eran románticas, ya estaban empoderadas.
Ariel, como vimos, lucha por su deseo.
La bella, de "La bella y la bestia",
rechaza al macho Gastón
que muere asesinado y doma a la bestia.
Jazmín, de Aladdín,
cambia las leyes del sultán.
Y Pocahontas, aún estando
enamorada de John Smith,
decide quedarse en la
tierra de sus ancestros.
Incluso la diversidad sexual
está incluida en el Disney de los 90.
Mulán, por ejemplo,
es la historia de una chica
que se mete en la guerra
travestida de varón.
Y que gana esa guerra
apoyado por un grupo de varones
travestidos de mujer.
Su trama de amor
es indiscutiblemente bisexual
e incluso podríamos decir que es queer.
En el final de la película Mulán
recibe la bendición de su familia,
de sus ancestros,
y del mismísimo emperador de China.
En 2001 se estrenó Shrek.
Y con esa película se abrió
una puerta muy interesante:
La de los discriminados.
Las tres grandes sagas de Dreamworks
-- Shrek, Kung Fu Panda
y Cómo entrenar a tu dragón --
tienen héroes feos, gordos
y personas con discapacidad.
Hasta la manera en que el bien y el mal
están tratados en las
películas infantiles cambió.
Ya casi no tenemos
malos malvados malísimos.
Incluso hay películas donde no hay malos,
como "Intensamente" o "Wall-E".
Hay películas en las cuales
el malo se pregunta
por su lugar en el mundo y cambia,
como "Mi villano favorito" o "Megamente".
Figuras históricamente aterradoras
como ogros, monstruos o vampiros
de pronto son personajes
con dilemas personales.
A esta manera de enfrentar
los conflictos la llamé la "post-maldad".
Sin embargo hay un argumento
de "Para leer al Pato Donald"
que todavía sigue en pie
50 años después.
Hay un conflicto que permanece silenciado.
Y ese es el conflicto de clase social.
Desde 1990 para acá,
hay una sola película
que trata directamente
el tema de la pobreza.
Esa película es "Aladdín".
Aladdín es un muchacho pobre de Agrabah
que convive con niños famélicos.
Al final de la película
cambia la situación de Aladdín,
cambia también la situación
de Jazmín, la mujer.
Pero los pobres siguen siendo pobres.
Tanto en la versión de 1992
como en la remake de 2019,
al final de la película
hay un palacio opulento lleno de riquezas
y afuera hay niños muriéndose de hambre.
Las películas animadas
producidas en EE.UU.
y consumidas en el mundo entero,
son fuertemente progresistas
en lo que respecta al género,
el racismo, la discriminación,
la discapacidad, la gordofobia.
Y son conservadoras con respecto
a los conflictos de clase social.
No me sorprendería que
en los próximos 10 o 15 años
se impusiera esta visión de mundo:
un capitalismo feminista multi-racial,
sexualmente diverso e inclusivo,
donde la diferencia entre ricos
y pobres es cada vez más grande.
(Aplausos)
Porque en Disney, en Dremworks,
en Illumination, en Pixar,
se reflejan y también se instalan
los valores de nuestra civilización.
Estas películas no son inocentes,
pero tampoco son el enemigo.
Podemos usarlas a nuestro favor.
Pero para que eso suceda
hay que entenderlas.
Y para entenderlas necesitamos
un nuevo enfoque crítico.
Para ver qué películas ven los chicos,
para discutirlas entre nosotros,
y luego con ellos.
Y, sobre todo, para saber
qué voces y qué valores
están siendo silenciados.
Pero volvamos a mi sillón.
Yo tengo un hijo de cuatro años
y quiero que deje de saltar.
Así que lo llamo:
"Goran, vení por favor".
Y bajo hasta su altura.
"Goran, te hago una pregunta.
¿Quién tiene la pata más grande,
Simba o Mufasa?"
"Mufasa".
"Vení, apoyá tu mano en la mía".
"¿Quién tiene la mano más grande,
vos o yo?"
"Vos".
"¿Entendés que si saltás en el sillón
te podés romper la cabeza?"
"Sí, papá".
"Entonces, ¿me vas a hacer caso?"
(Aplausos)
Los chicos están sentados en este sillón
mirando dibujos animados.
Nosotros creemos que es
entretenimiento, están embobados,
pero están sentados frente
a la maquinaria ideológica
más potente de nuestro siglo.
No los dejemos solos.
(Aplausos)